we're gonna need a little extra time at
airport security because I'm pretty sure
they're gonna want to patch it down show
insinuates the TSA gets their jollies
from patting down curvy ladies listen I
know at TSA and they don't like it any
more than you do they've touched so many
human squishy parts they might as well
be checking how right the zucchini are
at Whole Foods I'm a little torn because
I want a long time with Gloria
but I also like rubbing Manny's head for
good luck I'm not sure I understand why
Gloria's head isn't good enough wait
wait that was it
I've gone back over this laptop handoff
Zapruder style and I can't find a single
frame where anyone's hand is doing
anything that would have sent that email
I mean look at Gloria's hand here back
and to the left back and to the left
who was the email sent from shooter to
at grassy knoll com parents on computers
they can take us at 5:15 what are we 80
or 10:45 what are we 20 first off how
many people at 20 are eating at 10:45 8
o'clock or 9 o'clock maybe 10:45 that's
an early Taco Bell run it best second
eat your dinner at 5:15 like an adult
and shut up this goes beyond first world
problems at this point you just don't
deserve food most important plate it
ever saw I'm really gonna need you to
sparkle sweetie using your kids for your
own game also known as parenting okay I
get the point but these kids react way
too fast to the site of copulating
parentals it would take at least a
second or two to register what was
happening and then another second or two
for the curiosity of fate before the
panic set in these kids react like
they've just seen a terrifying jump
scare a home scare also Jesus I guess
you have to learn with three kids in the
house but helping stealth or filling
clear sex to where the kids couldn't
hear people and they were right outside
the door also also they have three kids
and Hailey as well in her teens at this
point none of them ever walked in on the
Phil and Claire tango yet oh my god oh
my god let's also not forget that this
is a documentary of some sort which
means this cameraman continued filming
as they disengage and got dressed what
the actual literal man I can still see
it see what there is less than half a
second between you opening the door and
us seeing your parents attempting to
build you a sibling and you turned your
head about 10 frames after that that's
right i frame by frame debt you know for
research also that means both Phil and
Claire got their [ __ ] together and cover
it all
Nadia bits in less than a second but
some top-notch reaction time right there
especially considering the show would
have us believe they were caught mid
thrust try Claire again I'm not getting
a signal relax we'll get her getting a
signal it's 2011 in a wealthy yellow a
suburb getting a signal it must be doing
well we can never seem to get a
reservation don't mean to keep harping
on this but they could get a reservation
just not when they wanted one those are
two very different things and a very
weak inciting incident to base one of
the show's subplots around and the next
time you call just tell them in old
movies the prospector or pirate or
whoever would often die right as they
were trying to reveal the location of
the loop that's why we call this the
treasure is buried in cliche also this
happens a couple more times so here's a
couple more sins for the decor Dias
interruptus Phil we are way past the
five-second rule buddy and the last time
I try the eight-minute rule I ended up
in the hospital because my intestines
were literally trying to escape from my
body so let's put the English muffin
down okay we need a game plan we need to
rehearse exactly what we're gonna say
honest question is this kind of sexual
shame and hang-up shtick really still
funny I mean my partner's brother walked
in on us one time so I walked out put my
arm around him and simply asked if he
was okay I mean I probably should have
put pants on first but then everything
seemed to go just fine
knock-knock and they were like who's
there and I was all someone who doesn't
want to see their parents doing it
that's why we knocked again this is this
is very rough but it doesn't have to be
filled knock knock who's there I'm N I'm
n who I'm n your mom see that wasn't so
hard is also what your mom said she's
really upset she big time god damn it I
hate when sitcoms do this
misunderstanding that could be cleared
up in two seconds dick it's not funny
now it's honestly never been funny
because it's not practical there are
ways to make this funny that aren't
being lazy as hell but sitcoms got a
sitcom this wine stain and the carpet of
the woman you want to woo so you've
arranged a playdate so you can get
reservations at her restaurant is the C
story SC story that I've ever had to see
stores are beyond blotting and rubbing I
think we've moved on to sweating and
crying it's exactly what my college
girlfriend said every time we tried to
tell Amelia what happened and then we'll
pay to have it cleaned if it can't be
cleaned Mitchell then you'll buy a new
rug you might have some kind of wine
stain warranty you can probably do
anything except whatever sitcom anything
you're about to do but carry on and yeah
yeah it's an alpaca blah blah blah
that doesn't make this plot unfolding
any less stupid no tell me cuz I think
I'm thinking the same thing I seriously
doubt that because now I'm thinking it
was junk Colin's house
Mitchell breaks the third wall here just
to remind us that they're having this
entire should we lie about this
conversation recorded for a documentary
humans in this show don't act like
humans who are being recorded and it's
supremely annoying also this means that
high-strung control freak Amelia not
only let a camera crew into her home
with two strangers she'd never met but
left them there with her deathly
allergic child seriously good thing we
had moms gas card and that another
camera crew just happened to follow you
as you rushed out when they were already
at least two cameras shooting at the
house one with Jay and Gloria in their
car two others following the Mitch and
cam carpet-cleaning caper how big is
this documentary crew I called a family
meeting when we switched to 1% milk 1%
bill seriously what's the other 99% what
is more important than putting a working
lock on a bedroom door
Al Bundy would be excellent at TV since
this whole story makes more sense if you
know I got a thing for thigh high boots
am I about to remove a sin for thigh
high boots damn straight I am look at
the sins don't matter why should the
removals I mean sure you could say it's
because this bit with Jay is actually
pretty funny but also have you seen
thigh high boots oh yeah I'm not an
idiot
he is turn the rug and she wouldn't find
the same four years or just come up with
a funnier incident I mean we're only in
season two guys Jackson's in it he
grabbed Lilly strawberry juice and
started drinking it why it's Jackson's
allergic to strawberries sir well close
up and go into anaphylactic shock I need
to inject him right now well now it
makes sense why cam decided to be so
conveniently specific about the type of
drink he was lying about comedy ladies
and gentlemen it's like you're shaking
hands but you're not using your hands at
all Hugh Koba 19
make sure you click that bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click it
manis with his father for the weekend so
Jay and I are flying to Vegas and the
only restaurant within walking distance
is swarm a city there's a shwarma joint
about two blocks from here I don't know
what it is but I want to try it you were
on fire lady what is wrong with you
people
I'm sorry tell them what hello what are
those oh well it's cranberry juice
cranapple great wait exactly didn't
drink the juice I stepped on Lily's bag
in the juice box fella we panicked
because we heard you on the photo we
can't afford John Collins right you let
me to stick this